[Music]
let's get it started in salt lake city
utah brett joins us there brett how can
we help
hey what's up guys um i'm 34 married
with five kids i'm a high school auto
shop teacher
and i have a pretty good thing going
i've been doing it for six years my wife
and i are getting on the same page
financially finally we've been paying
off a lot of debt um and i have some
retirement starting it feels great yeah
uh but my wife
has moved all around she look and she
lived in the south she wants to get back
to the south too many mormons in utah
she wants to get out oh i've lived here
my whole life yeah i've lived here my
i've lived here my whole life and so i'm
a little timid um we have we have a
mortgage and a heloc so the heloc is the
is the sore spot um
and so and and uh the kicker is we have
five kids but we we don't have our
basement finished
so
she needs more room for the kids and she
says hey if you get a teaching job in
the south you could sell the house we
owe about 180 plus 53 on the heloc we
can sell the house for 550 560
and buy something cheaper in the south
so and have more space for the kids you
know trade our life here for a life
there sell the house brett i think your
wife's making a lot of sense
what's the hold up
what do you want george and i to say i
think your wife's got a really nice
listen
i know but i've got a good gig here i
get uh you know the the teacher job is
great love the kids uh my work
contributes 10
to my 401k and before i got this job i
had no savings i was terrible with money
so we've got 10 percent going to 401k
that's free money that's part of my
compensation it doesn't come out of my
salary household income i make 72 she
makes about 10 doing eyelash extensions
and coaching gymnastics
i'm just scared to leave my good thing
because i'm afraid and i've looked into
other states they're not going to have
the educated retirement and the pay
won't be quite as good
so you've looked at specific southern
locations that she's kind of said i'd be
willing to go here you looked at teacher
salaries she said texas to texas to
north carolina the traditional south
i've been looking and you know more
stuff's gonna pop up
right and so and again just to clarify
uh you don't think you can't you haven't
found a location in
any of those states whatever the range
is where you're making 75 and you've got
a good 401k
no everything on on on indeed is showing
55 and then you have to pay into the
state retirement it's not it's you know
you can't get into a 401k
but i don't think this is a i think you
called
um
with a presenting kind of a money
slash i'm right employment work question
well i think this is a relationship
issue before we get to the heloc okay
we're going to address the money and the
work stuff that's what you've presented
i think this is a relationship issue
how big of a deal is it to the wife to
get out of utah
i just need to know it may not be that
big of a deal how big of a deal is it
it's a major deal she she's in georgia
louisiana she wants the kids she thinks
the south is great we've traveled the
south i think you know life is a little
slower a little simpler hey look we
couldn't afford to live to buy our house
now the market has gone so crazy right
you know all right so here's why i asked
the question
if if it's not going to go away if she's
not going to keep bringing this up
then you're going to have to get
realistic
about what a move looks like
and how you're going to make the money
you want to make and get that you're
going to have to really consider that i
mean it's
you could put her off on this and go hey
i don't know but i mean that's the key
issue no i'm open to it
i'm open to it okay i just don't feel
like we'll have it you know i'm painting
my picture with the dave ramsey
saving that 401k hit the roth right do
all these things and i'm finally
starting to see some traction and i'm
just scared that i've got it too good i
think you have a false narrative i i
think you need some more facts i know
you've done some research and i'm not
doubting you but i think there's a false
narrative that you can't make the money
you make now and also find a really
great investment strategy whether it's
through the school system are you doing
it yourself george speak to the uh i
think he's hung up on that 401k and i
understand why sure well there's free
money there but here's the thing you've
got a lot going on you've got a pile of
debt to clean up are you are you
investing past the ten percent or is
that it
um i've been doing a few hundred a month
and i've been doing a few hundred in the
raw okay well you're currently you're
following brett's plan because our plan
says you're pausing all investing while
we get rid of the debt and you have a
fully funded emergency fund do you guys
have an emergency fund
uh no we just have a thousand we're
still on baby step two so to your point
my question is should
i'm worried about losing out on the
compound interest if i stop investments
to pay off this fifty three thousand
dollar heloc and that's if i go crazy at
it it's going to take me if you were
worried about compound interest you
would have been investing when you were
22.
and so let's not be worried about that
right now let's be worried about
cleaning up the debt because then you're
not going to be investing 10 plus 100
you're going to be investing 15 and
you're going to be investing for your
kids college and have all that money for
those five sweet kids of yours to go to
college debt-free and for you to pay off
your household they're home for college
oh they're on their own
i'm trying to retire my wife and i well
dude i'm trying to put you on a path
all right so clarification
is the heloc the only debt
credit cards car payment nothing else
nothing no that's what i thought so the
heloc is the only debt and we've dug
ourselves out of that so you know what
do you mean you dug yourself out well
you haven't oh you mean you had more i'm
saying we've recently come to this spot
where we have paid off we got rid of the
car with the pain that we've come here
we're doing better we've got the heloc
and the mortgage left that's it yeah
okay he's worked his way down to the
heloc sure i look yeah george my wife
wants more space for the kids i listen
no dude let me just tell you something
right now your wife wants out of utah
the more space for the kids is a
secondary i know listen dude i've been
married almost 24 years
i think you got more homework to do
you can invest okay if you sell the
house george here's where i'm going on
the financial i already got the math if
he sells the house
and they have a really huge they pay off
the heloc they pay off the house they
got a huge down payment in a house in
the southeast you'll have 300k even
after closing a huge down payment and
you can get caught up on the investment
strategy whether or not the school's got
a great plan or not am i right george
yes you need to be investing 15 of your
income i don't want you relying on one
certain employer for your retirement
plan you need to be doing this out of
your own business i get that and so you
get i love the free money it's a great
plan and the truth is cost of living in
the south may be a lot cheaper than
where you're at so that's 72
making 55.60 might feel just the same
because of cost of living
especially when you have a 300 000 down
payment and now your mortgage is real
small if one at all now you feel like
you're wrong
yeah listen you got to do your research
man
south it's got all kinds of great guys
i moved to the south from the north and
i'll tell you game changer he's not
going back folks this is a boston boy
who loves the southeast
uh sell move to the south happy wife
happy life no debt investing i'm a no
foreigner